Tattoos are a touchy subject here,...
"They're an insult to God!" blusters one man.
More importantly, they clash with Confucian belief,...
...which is still strong here.
Most Koreans believe that their bodies are gifts from their ancestors,...
...so they should not be tampered with.
It's not surprising then that many Koreans are averse to having tattoos.
In Europe in the past,...
...tattoos were used to mark all kinds of criminals, slaves, and undesirables.
Recently, tattoos are in fashion.
One Korean living in London was shocked to observe that:
"Seven out of ten people here wear a tattoo like a shirt or a hat.
Are they all gangsters?
In Korea, many people think only criminals have tattoos."
Attitudes in Korea still aren't much different.
Consequently, getting a tattoo in Korea is quite difficult...
...especially because it's still illegal to give someone one without license.
But that hasn't stopped one tattooist based in Hongik University area,...
...who claims that most of his customers are regular people, mostly in their 20s.
"There are many artists like musicians, dancers, actors,...
...and painters among my customers, but I also have  inked university students,...
...office workers and even housewives."
Many Koreans do get tattooed temporarily when they're abroad.
So tattoos are not that taboo at least when one is on vacation.
Tattooists do have one final piece of advice,...
..."Getting a tattoo is like getting married.
You should be willing to live with your cartoon friend...
'until death do you part'."